Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David P.
This really cracked me up when I heard it
yesterday. We played this clip of MyPillow Mike
Lindell saying he found out that a supposedly
eight hundred and fifty year old person voted
in the 2020 election. That's part of the fraud.
Here is a caller making a similar point. It's a
joke, but they do it beautifully.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, this is
Stuart from Wisconsin,
Speaker 1: by the way,
even the detail of pronouncing Wisconsin,
Wisconsin the way Mike Pillow did,
this is a perfect voicemail down to the last
Speaker 4: detail. And I have you know that I know
two people who wanted one is 53 years old and the
other is and twenty seven years old, right along
Kettering and Johnny Hopkins. And they used
to play that shit every day. These guys voted.
Speaker 1: Imagine it's crazy. Yeah. Seven
hundred and fifty three year olds are out
there voting. It's wild, wild times. I'm glad
that essentially everybody in my audience
seems to have realized the absurdity of of Mike
Pillow's claims. We have a fantastic bonus show
for you today. As many of you know, gas powered
leaf blowers, I believe, are the devil's work.
I believe they are the mark of the Beast,
quite frankly. California is working to ban
gas powered leaf blowers and lawn mowers.
Their motivations may be environmental,
minor, sound pollution oriented. We will talk
about that. Also, interest in the flu shot
this season is not very high. I got my flu
shot. We will talk about why interest seems
to not be very high on today's bonus show.
And lastly, we have the first ever approval.
For a malaria vaccine. Huge. We'll talk about
the implications and more on today's bone is
show. Sign up at join Packman dot com. You'll get
instant access to the world famous bonus show.
I'll see you then or otherwise. We'll be back
Unidentified: with a new show tomorrow.